(soft electronic music)
- Ahoy!
Michael here to finally
cover one of the zaniest
and most beloved animes to
ever sail the great blue.
That's right: One Piece.
The story of Luffy D. Monkey's quest
to become king of the pirates
is filled with unforgettable characters,
incredible adventures, and a
literal boatload of laughs.
(crew laughing)
But is there something deeper happening
beneath the chaotic waves?
Specifically, can One Piece
actually tell us something
about organized society,
or even how to rebel against
a society that sucks?
We think so, and we'll explain
in this Wisecrack Edition
on One Piece: How to Live Outside the Law.
And spoilers ahead for about a fifth
of the total run of One Piece.
But if you like this, let us know,
and we can make another
video in the future.
For the uninitiated,
One Piece is a show about
Luffy, an aspiring pirate king
who rounds up a crew of
misfits to sail the sea
in pursuit of the titular
"one piece" treasure.
These aren't your
run-of-the-mill kooks, either.
Luffy is a "rubber man,"
meaning he can stretch his
body Mr. Fantastic-style,
a power he indulges to adorable
effect at every opportunity.
(Luffy screaming)
His pal Zorro is a
pirate-hunter-turned-pirate
who wields not one, not
two, but three swords.
One is for his mouth, obviously.
Nami reads relatively normal,
but she's still a sneaky
thief and kick-ass navigator.
The chef, Sanji, is a
horned-up nicotine fiend
who loves fine dining and kicking ass.
Their engineer Usop is a pathological liar
who has a tough time
distinguishing his fantasies
from reality.
Oh, and their doctor is a
magical deer who can talk.
When we say misfits, we mean it.
(speaking in foreign language)
That said, maybe a magical deer doctor
wouldn't be on my case about
my cholesterol levels so much.
And these aren't the only
weirdos in this world.
In fact, almost every
single character is bizarre,
and that's largely the point.
The farther from land you go,
the stranger the adventures become.
It's almost like, when you're
out at sea, the rules of land,
or the logic of terrain, no longer apply.
So, why does this matter?
We can answer that with
the help of bald icon,
leather aficionado,
and French philosopher Michel Foucault.
Let's start with what Foucault
thought about terrain and roads.
In his essay "Of Other Spaces,"
Foucault explained that different
spaces in modern society
function as a network;
that is, they exist in
relation to one another.
He writes that, "One could describe,
via the cluster of relations
that allows them to be defined,
the sites of temporary relaxation:
cafes, cinemas, beaches.
Likewise one could describe,
via its network of relations,
the closed or semi-closed sites of rest:
the house, the bedroom,
the bed, et cetera."
That is to say that there are places
where certain rules apply.
You don't run around
screaming in a movie theater,
and you aren't getting into
bed to do a Jazzercise routine.
These places have defined functions,
and as such, have defined rules.
We see plenty of the expectations
surrounding various kinds of
land-based spaces in One Piece.
Like when Luffy is
caught breaking the law,
which is sort of his favorite hobby.
Or when the crew is forced
to confront the reality of farming,
among other land-locked jobs,
and the costs that come with them.
However, Foucault points
out that some spaces
are free from these sorts of rules.
These he calls heterotopia.
And unlike what you might be thinking,
Hetero-topias don't refer
to a Buffalo Wild Wings
next to a GAP outlet.
Heterotopias are
typically enclosed spaces,
worlds within worlds, if you will.
Fittingly, for our purposes,
he identifies the boat as a
"heterotopia par excellence,"
describing the boat as "a
floating piece of space,
a place without a place,
that exists by itself,
that is closed in on
itself and at the same time
is given over to the infinity of the sea."
When it comes to modern transportation,
the way we move has
become largely codified:
we drive cars on government-paved roads
at government-enforced speed limits
and take our shoes off for the privilege
of flying across the country
in a rattling tin can with wings.
But when you traverse the sea,
you're a lot more free and unrestricted.
Sure there are laws,
but as anyone who saw
Captain Phillips knows,
it's a lot easier to break them.
A heterotopia's specific
function and population
creates a unique type of
freedom for its inhabitants.
As scholar Ibrahim Marazka
explains, a heterotopia
"enables human agency,
because it allows the freedom
to create other rationalities
and to follow them."
Think of how, on The Going Merry,
the crew can act like absolute maniacs.
(speaking in foreign language)
Or how they can derail
their quest at any time
to, say, help reinstall a missing monarch
or bring a dragon colony back to life.
As Luffy explains, he doesn't
want to be pirate king
because he wants people
to bow down to him,
he simply wants to be free.
(speaking in foreign language)
And life on The Going Merry
enables that pure state of freedom.
Heck, Luffy is completely clueless about,
and ambivalent towards, money.
(speaking in foreign language)
(gulps)
(shouts in foreign language)
And his life, like his corporeal
form, is pretty malleable:
throughout the crew's adventures,
they play a wide variety of roles
and are able to go wherever they choose.
Sometimes they're saviors,
sometimes they're criminals,
sometimes they're just
trying to enjoy a dinner
uninterrupted by pirate fights.
And it's not just that
they move around a lot
and make zany friends.
They also use this freedom
to fight against oppressive powers
that might seek to restrict them.
The crew often finds itself
in places run by corrupt governments,
or taken over by the Marines,
or even usurped by evil pirates
who, not coincidentally,
have often given up their
seafaring gig for a life on land.
Fittingly, Foucault wrote that,
"In civilizations without
boats, dreams dry up,
espionage replaces adventure,
and the police the pirates."
We see this literalized
repeatedly in One Piece,
which takes us to places where pirates
have given up the freedom of heterotopias
to impose a very not-fun rule of law.
Obviously this isn't the only story
where a crew of pirates
represent radical freedom,
but the cool thing about One
Piece is how explicit it is.
We see a world government that is corrupt,
and uses its power to oppress people
and inflict harm on weaker communities.
We see our heroes frequently matched up
against these evil systems.
And according to scholar Juilian Reid,
the freedom afforded to
nomadic groups, like pirates,
puts them in the best possible position
to take on powerful enemies.
Wisecrack favorites Gilles
Deleuze and Felix Guatarri
drew an important distinction
between two visions of war.
There's war as a state apparatus
that uses violence to control its people,
intimidate enemies or
be straight-up jerks.
And then, there's the war machine,
i.e. the eternal human
impulse to struggle,
sometimes violently, for
the sake of differentiation;
that is, a struggle in which people
want to affirm themselves
on their own terms
rather than in relation
to some opposing force.
It's basically the opposite
of what philosophers
call dialectical thought,
which always defines two opposites
precisely in their
opposition to one another,
i.e., hot and cold, up and down,
Taco Bell and Pepto-Bismol.
As Reid explains, Deleuze
thought that when we define war
as an instrument of only
the state apparatus,
we create limitations,
because "war exists
both inside and outside
of the domain of political sovereignty."
Basically, Deleuze thinks
you don't need to be a nation
to wage a war.
In fact, he uses evidence from ethnography
to argue that nomadic
tribes often waged war
not to protect a state, but
to stop a centralized state
from forming in the first place.
In this view, war has
been, and still can be,
a valuable form of resistance
against state control.
And we recently did a video
arguing that the human impulse for war
isn't really that natural,
so be sure and check that out
for a different perspective.
Because of this, Deleuze
sees the war machine
as inherently antagonistic
to the state apparatus,
though the state may try its
darndest to appropriate it.
Deleuze ultimately believed
that the war machine
could be transformative and
offer alternatives to the state,
which, he thought, limited possibilities.
Take the opposing ways
that states and nomads
navigate space: states organize it,
determine ownership of it,
and place other arbitrary
restrictions on it,
which is why I'm no longer welcome
at Yosemite National Park.
It's a long story.
In contrast, nomads live freely
without territorializing
the spaces they inhabit.
States might define nomads
in relation to themselves,
but nomads driving the war machine
are striving for a pure affirmation
that differentiates them from the state.
We see the nomadic war
machine throughout One Piece.
Pretty much every narrative arc
is resolved with a big fight,
with the stakes almost always being
the freedom of a character,
or an entire community
or sometimes just a cute dragon.
Like the time Luffy and co take on Arlong,
or fight to liberate Alabasta.
And this is a key way in
which the anarchic nature
of the Going Merry's crew
can teach us about the world.
They are violent, but their
violence maintains a code,
and it's nomadic in
that it's often directed
against the state.
They don't belong to a military structure
that serves the needs and
demands of the sovereign.
What's more, remember how our
friends live in a heterotopia?
That gives them the ability
to see outside the rules
and norms of organized society.
As a result, they aren't
confined to a single worldview.
You could call them psychic nomads.
That doesn't mean they're
wanderers with telekinesis:
psychic nomadism simply means
that you pick and choose
from a great big buffet of worldviews:
religious, political, ethical,
while rejecting aspects of those views
that you don't find as tasty.
For example, Luffy embraces the violence
and chaos of the pirate worldview,
but rejects the cruelty and selfishness.
And Chopper views the world
through the lens of magic,
being a talking deer and all,
while still abiding by
the science of medicine.
The result can be, as you
might guess, somewhat chaotic.
Sometimes the crew has to save a kingdom
and install a rightful ruler.
Sometimes they have to get
rid of rulers altogether.
It all depends on the scenario,
and on who happens to be onboard the ship.
Rather than fighting one
political ideology with another,
they're fighting against
ideology altogether,
and defending some type
of formless freedom
or self-actualization.
They don't want to exist
in relation to the state,
they just want to exist.
(speaking in foreign language)
The key consistency, though,
is that the crew resists
the monopoly over violence
granted to those in power,
in large part thanks to their
relative egalitarianism.
Now of course we're not
saying you should buy a boat
and sail around the Florida panhandle
to beat up the Coast Guard.
But if that's your bag,
who are we to stop you?
But you can still take a
valuable lesson from One Piece.
Modern social movements are
often under a lot of pressure
to strive for ideological consistency
when they resist state power.
In contrast, the One
Piece crew doesn't stake
a consistent position in their resistance.
The way they fight back doesn't always
have to look the same, or
uphold the same values.
Rather, they use their flexibility,
and their position as
residents of a heterotopia,
to change themselves to
fit the crisis at hand.
This mutability as a form of resistance
is very literally displayed in Luffy,
who can stretch his body
into all sorts of forms as he fights.
The crew's mobility, both
literally and ideologically,
is its own form of power,
and maybe more importantly
for our swashbuckling homies,
it's a form of positive freedom;
that is, a freedom which
is more about freedom for,
rather than a freedom from,
some type of oppression or control.
In this way, One Piece shows us the value
of movement and flexibility,
and the unique power of
the pirate and the nomad.
These lifestyles that are
able to adjust, change,
and accommodate new circumstances
aren't just excuses to
wear cool hats and bling,
but are in fact ways to
more effectively think
about ourselves as
political and social actors.
But what do you guys think?
Does the Go Merry crew show us the power
of the nomadic war machine?
Should we ditch land
for the pure heterotopic
freedom of a boat?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out
our revamped Patreon page
for loads of exclusive new content.
Stab that subscribe button
like you're cutting a steak
with your mouth knife,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat electronic music)
Energy!
Okay, sorry if that hurt your
ears if you had headphones on.